[Music]
this was pre lockdown a performance of
Macbeth when hundreds of schoolchildren
packed into Shakespeare's Globe only the
plague forced it to close as the
pandemic now has threatening its very
existence with losses of more than two
million pounds a month there's now hope
here thanks to the government's rescue
package but not certainty the anxiety
level that has been at full capacity for
15 weeks has gone down slightly because
there is as I say there's hope for the
sector but it's it's not sort of popping
the champagne bottle it's not safe for
any of us to say whew it's it's all over
by any stretch of the imagination but
what this is is a lifeline and we're
very grateful for you the relief fund of
1.5 7 billion pounds is being seen as a
reprieve not just for theatres but also
museums music venues heritage sites and
galleries all of which are eligible but
even the culture Secretary acknowledges
its limits sadly not everyone's going to
be able to survive and not every job is
going to be protected and sadly we will
I have to be honest with you of course
we'll see further redundancies today's
announcement comes after weeks of
warning from the creative sector that
the UK is facing an irreversible
cultural catastrophe and although there
is widespread support the devil will
undoubtedly be in the detail a number of
theatres have recently announced
closures and redundancies including the
Theatre Royal Plymouth who say the
damage is already done
if there isn't a major intervention
coming
we know that come September or October
we won't have to make a further much
more draconian cut either to cut another
huge slice of the stuff or wine the
whole organisation down into a mosque or
to hibernate
now the sector can look to the future at
least but it's still very uncertain if
any theatres will
able to open this year the most
important thing now for most theatres
for instance is do they do they get to
do their panto because that's where most
people go to the theater and it will be
lovely to know that this had stopped in
November redundancies and allowance here
just a plan into next year because of
course as you say the pickup early on is
going to be nervous and small and we are
going to have to restructure the
government has vowed to preserve local
institutions as well as the UK's
creative crown jewels and our future
cultural health will depend on it
Lucy Cotter Sky News